they can't let you do this anti man it's
the only way they'll understand believe
me the only
way please don't do this these people
have done nothing to
you ironic you care for them but they
care for No One save
themselves I on the other hand will make
them care Connor you're sick please no
Adam my mind has never been clearer help
me to make them see as well we can't
force the world to be what it should
be it has to happen naturally not
through Act of Terror but by
example that's what Heroes
do I don't want to hurt you but you have
to be
stucked
never are they
dead you can't be blue Marvel's got to
be all
right
blue Marvel blue
Marvel this gentleman is the blue Marvel
America's blue Marvel The Magnificent
master of Might the man of Marvels the
blue blue bomber of battle a
negro bits of his mask were torn
revealing different parts of his face we
ran this through military RMI protocols
and got a match Adam Bernard brashier
won a handful of medals in Korea
graduated Magna kumla from Cornell in 54
electrical engineering PhD in
theoretical
physics definitely not your average
colored spin out of space he helped us
with that meteor when the Enterprise was
damaged in the Pacific he lifted the
damn thing out of the water and flew it
all the way
home and don't forget that hydrogen bomb
incident Polaris aboard the Nautilus
malfunction he got it into the air and
out of Harm's Way just before it
exploded in his hands over the
Atlantic in this social climate a
colored man with that kind of power is a
problem we would not be able to handle
should things get out of hand Miss Mr
President if I may I can appreciate your
sense of liberty and justice for all sir
but you have to understand we are on the
brink of a sociopolitical watershed in
our country's
History Civil Rights will reach a fever
pit in the next few years the presence
of a superpowered black man of that
level well upset the apple cart is that
right you are Kelly Sir Robert Kelly
NSA the whole country has turned on him
in a matter of
months last week he saved 16 children
from a burning oranage and whes threw
rocks and bottles at him hled racial
Slayers that make a Clansman blush and
that was up north some cop shoots him
the bullet ricochets kills an old woman
and they blame the blue
Marvel many of his own people colors
don't even like him they expect him to
be some kind of negro Messiah and kill
all the white people they burn down
their own neighborhoods and protest cuz
he refused to lead them in a genocide
against
us caught between two
worlds and all he's done for this
country save the world from disasters
and
despots yet he can't even eat a ham
sandwich one of our cafeterias in his
own hometown
we could have taken down the white and
colored only signs years ago but we
didn't could have abolished Jim Crow
completely but again we didn't but now
that a colored man has come along who
can stand up to us we become paranoid
frightened
children you're the president Jack it's
your decision no it's the world's
decision
we both know why we're here my
grandfather used to tell me about the
signs that said Irish need not apply but
they don't say that now do they sir I'll
get right to the point the world's
afraid of you Mr brashier they have
visions of a vengeful superpowered negro
taking over the
world everyone is afraid of people are
things they don't
understand and from my experience they
don't really want to understand ignorant
isn't Bliss it's
familiar and unfortunately there's
comfort in
that so how do we educate them sir only
time can educate and she isn't on our
side what are you really trying to tell
me
sir I'm asking you to stand down to
cease all your activities as the blue
Marvel effective
[Music]
immediately for how long
this is the best I can do for you it's a
presidential medal of freedom the
highest honor that can be bestowed upon
a civilian for his or her undying
humanitarian efforts for for it's been
an
honor
[Music]
sir you did the right thing Jack it was
the only now Bobby
please how could it ever be right to
tell a man he can't be who he is
I only pray that should we ever need him
again he'll find in his heart to forgive
us thank you for coming on short notice
General Mason so what are my orders
these come from the
top we'll need you to keep an eye on
him do you have a fiance no sir good
m